[Applaudissements]
quoi toi plaisir qu'est ce que vous
pensez des transports en commun
parisiens plutôt du bien je n'ai pas de
voiture je n'en vois pas du tout
l'utilité habitant à paris est donc
d'accord et votre est il en pense quoi
eh bien je suis pas rien les oreilles
bon bah je vois je suis tombé dans le
paddock que c'est triste qui pourrait
sourire et peut-être se mettre à poil et
vauxhall en pense quoi
dis donc pas je sais très bien que rire
et que tes questions merci
j'aime bien les transports parisiens
généralement et votre à elle en pense
quoi
jpost grosso modo la même et chausse ses
skis
quand on arrive à certaines périodes il
fait quand même assez chaud il fait
assez froid et c'est vrai que d'accord
et votre sol en pense quoi
la même chose c'est insupportable
hamon données transport transport entend
parler que de ça c'est sa meilleure
jamais s'améliorer toi fais plaisir en
torrent moi aussi ça faisait longtemps
attendu qu'est ce qu'on pense et
transports en commun parisiens
c'est pratique ça tu as you et vos
frères il en pense quoi
ouais parce qu'il ya toujours un cola
pour sortes et de toutes les données
qu'il collecte un sur deux frères
ah merde atomique
merci